what is it you haven't sort of said it
explicitly but this relationship between
meat intake and the incidence of cancer
like what is going on there because I
think when you say that to somebody like
basically saying meat causes cancer yeah
I mean I don't say that now the World
Health Organization says that so does
every other major Association I think
the National Cancer Institute and no
doubt this is a USDA I think is also now
reduced recommendation on protein
because of that so red meat particularly
is now recognized by almost every major
Association specialized in cancer to be
a risk factor in our case you know we
had multiple papers we and Harvard
School of Public Health they published a
series of papers all of them in
agreement with this idea particularly
for red meat but just also for prod high
protein so after our paper we publish
one with the edge of a neutral Harvard
and also confirming that the plant-based
diet was protective compared to a
variety of diets that included a high
protein from animal sources